hi I'm emilga from Carnegie Mellon
University and in this talk I'll tell
you about work that I did with my inhala
where we show some separations in proof
complexity
the systems that we will be concerned
with in this talk are slightly unusual
in that I don't expect you to have heard
of them but they're all meant to
formalize a technique that I'm sure
you're familiar with and have used
informally when writing your
mathematical proofs so hopefully you'll
find these per systems interesting
the systems we will be separating in
this talk are going to be built on top
of resolution which is arguably the
simplest interesting system in
propositional proof complexity and also
the most widely studied one
so you may have at least heard of
resolution but just in case you haven't
here's what resolution does
it works with propositional formulas in
conjunctive normal form or CNF for short
which we view as a set of clauses
and resolution repeats such formulas by
repeatedly applying the inference rule
that you see here to derive new Clauses
eventually deriving the empty class
in this role A and B are clauses and X
is a variable
from the two Clauses a or x b or not X
this rule derives A or B
and this rule is sound that is any
satisfying assignment to its premises
also satisfies its conclusion
so if we can derive the empty Clause
from a set of Clauses using this rule
then that set of Clauses is
unsatisfiable because the empty Clause
is just false
in this sense resolution is a refutation
system because it refutes the
satisfiability of aecnf formula
despite this
throughout this talk I'll keep saying
proof to stand for refutation because
it's more conventional and by a proof I
will mean a proof of unsatisfiability
which we interpret to be the same thing
as a reputation of satisfiability
next I'll show you an example of a
resolution proof so that everything I
just said is clear
here's a formula gamma in CNF with three
variables and five clauses
and for just this slide I'm denoting
negation by over lines like this to save
some space
and this formula is unsatisfiable
and here's a proof in resolution
the inferences here are arranged in a
tree-like manner
in this tree like proof each horizontal
line is an application of the resolution
rule
and the leaves are clauses from the
original formula and the root is the
empty clause
as you see here for instance resolution
allows us to derive Z from these two
Clauses by cutting away the variable Y
and so on until the empty class is
derived
it's not necessary to arrange the proof
in this manner and often we just write
it out as a sequence of Clauses such
that each Clause is either a clause from
the original formula or is derived from
two previous clause in the sequence
using the resolution rule here I've
grayed out the Clauses that belong to
the original formula so there are just
five Clauses that were derived using
resolution with the final being the
empty class
this is also a good time to talk about
proof size which we Define as the number
of Clauses that you have in the sequence
making up a resolution proof so for
instance for the sequence like proof its
size is just 10.
and this matter of proof size is the
primary concern of proof complexity
more specifically we are interested for
a person p in this quantity SP of gamma
which is the size of a smallest P proof
of the formula gamma
one of the goals of proof complexity is
to relate different proof systems by
this quantity and here are two relations
for different systems p and Q we say
that P simulates Q if for all formulas
proofs in the system P are not too much
larger than the producing Q this is what
the statement here says a bit more
formally
and we say p is exponentially separated
from Q if there is some infinite
sequence of formulas admitting short
proofs in P while requiring long proofs
in q
a lot of proof complexity relates
different concrete systems to one
another using these Notions
and now here's a list of some commonly
studied concrete proof systems
the particular choice of the systems
that I listed here is not really
important because the main point that I
want to emphasize is that they're all
capturing some version of a mode of
mathematical reasoning
for instance frege is like the usual
textbook style propositional logical
system
Frankie is a version where you're
allowed to Define some new variables to
abbreviate Expressions substitution
phrase is another version where you're
allowed to reinstantiate previously per
statements by renaming their variables
kind of similar to how you first prove a
Lemma and then use it several times in
different contexts other systems
correspond to geometric reasoning or
algebraic reasoning and so on
the bottom line is all of these are
motivated by some part of the
mathematical practice
and the proof systems that we will focus
on in this talk are going to be
motivated in a similar manner
specifically they're motivated by the
use of the following phrase
which like I said at the beginning I'm
sure you've all written in some proof
you often use this phrase to simplify or
shorten proofs which makes it really
natural to study from the perspective of
proof complexity because we are
interested in improved size
you may say for instance without loss of
generality assume X is greater than or
equal to Y by improving your result that
is unchanged by swapping X and Y because
the proof of the other case is
essentially the same or maybe you're
talking about graph coloring and you
pick some vertex and assume it's colored
red because if it weren't then you could
just swap red with some other color in
your proof
or if you're proving some results about
a random variable you may assume for
Simplicity that it has expected value 0
when you can recover the more General
Case by translation
and there are plenty of such examples
so in this talk we will focus on
pre-systems that capture this kind of
reasoning at the level of CNF formulas
note that really strong systems like
external frege or substitution frege can
already simulate this kind of reasoning
but they can also do much more and none
of the other systems that I previously
showed enabled this kind of reasoning so
we will be looking at proof systems that
are meant to capture the ability to
reason without generality without going
Overkill in terms of strength
and we will start with a really simple
example of what we would like to be able
to do because the instances that I have
on this slide are rather informal and a
bit too General
so now I'll try to show an example of
what it even means to derive Clauses
without loss optionality
for this example let gamma be some
formula in which literal not X does not
appear and to be concrete and simple
let's say gamma has just a single Clause
X or Y
now
without loss of Charity we make a large
gamma with the Clause X
and we need to justify this just as you
would do when making an assumption
without loss of reality in your proofs
here the justification is that we are
only trying to prove unsatisfiability
and adding X to gamma does not change
its satisfiability status
in other words gamma is satisfiable if
and only if gamma n axis this is because
since X does not occur negatively in
gamma it cannot possibly hurt to assume
that it is said to be true which we
achieve by adding the Clause X to gamma
and here is an important thing to notice
about this
the Clause X is not necessarily
logically implied by gamma in the proof
systems that I showed a few slides back
with the exceptions of extended and
substitution frege you can only derive
things that are logically implied
but in the current situation X may not
be implied because there might be an
assignment satisfying gamma without
satisfying X
this does not mean that we are doing
something else out
and more generally we will call it
Clause redundant if it can be added to a
formula without affecting its
satisfiability
and we will define proof systems that
allow us to derive redundant clauses
we need to restrict our notion of
redundancy though because as it's
written here it is just a semantic
property and we cannot necessarily check
redundancy efficiently but the whole
point of proofs is that they should be
ease to validate so we will work with
syntactic criteria that are sufficient
but not necessary for redundancy and we
will use those criteria to Define our
inference rules
to keep things simple and talk I'm
actually Define only the simplest
redundancy Criterion
the rest of them are various relaxation
relaxations of the definition that we
are now looking at which is the notion
of a block clause
now let P be a literal
we say that a clause C of the form P or
C Prime is blocked for p with respect to
a formula gamma if for every Clause B in
gamma that contains not p
the results of applying the resolution
rule to C and D which gives the Clause
you see here is tautological namely it
contains complementary literals
in case this was hard to parse let's
make it clearer with an example
example C is blocked for X with respect
to gamma
let's check this carefully
here x plays the role of p in the
definition and the Clause y or not C
plays the role of C Prime
we need to look at the Clauses in gamma
that contain not X and we can disregard
the others
it is easy to see that for this first
Clause the condition is satisfied
because resolving it with C over X is y
or Nazi or not Y where why and not y are
complementary
and a similar thing is true for the
second Clause because this time we get y
or not C or Z so C is indeed blocked for
x
and we call it Clause blocked if it
contains a literal that it is blocked
for
the notion of a blocked Clause was
defined by Oliver Coleman and he showed
that block Clauses are redundant so they
can be used to Define inference rules
and obviously we can efficiently check
whether a clause is blocked or not so we
now have what we wanted
and before proceeding notice the
following about this definition
if not P does not occur anywhere in
gamma then C is automatically blocked
this means in particular that if p is a
new variable relative to gamma then C is
blocked regardless of anything else
with that in mind let's continue
we are now ready to talk about the
inference rules
here just to be formal I'm defining a
proof like we saw at the resolution but
in a more generic way
this time a proof is a sequence of
Clauses where each Clause is either in
the original formula or is derived from
the set of all previous Clauses
According to some rule of the Pro System
attempt the rules that we will have are
the resolution rule which you've already
seen the extension rule I mentioned
earlier which allows us to make
definitions by introducing the three
Clauses that Express this formula
here we call X an extension variable and
it should be a new variable that is it
should not occur in the original formula
or any of the previous clause in the
proof or the right hand side of the
definition so in particular X is
different from the variables of p and Q
which are arbitrary literals and we
finally have some redundancy rule which
allows us to derive a syntactically
redundant Clause with respect to the set
of all the previous Clauses occurring in
the proof
with different choices of those
inference rules we obtain different
proof systems and writing R to denote
the base system which is resolution
ER is extended resolution which has the
resolution rule plus the extension rule
BC is the blocked Clauses system which
has resolution plus the ability to add
block Clauses and there is also this
system that I denote by BC minus if you
recall I mentioned that block Clauses
could include new variables similar to
extension so this BC minus is the
version of BC where we disallow new
variables from appearing in the proof
and although I haven't explicitly told
you about them they're all the
generalizations of block Clauses which
give rise to birth systems and they can
also be restricted in a similar manner
to disallow new variables
this restriction is really significant
because it turns out that without it BC
actually generalizes extended resolution
which we were trying to avoid in the
first place because it is too powerful
so I claim that for those syntactic
redundancy based systems the versions
without new variables are much more
interesting this is because they are
still strictly above resolution and
allow us to reason without loss of
generality but they do not go all the
way up to the strength of external
resolution our focus in this work is on
those versions without new variables
because certain variants turn out to be
quite interesting
here are some results already known
about those Pro systems
these combinatorial principles which
require large proofs in many proof
systems all turn out to be easy for a
modest generalization of PC minus
despite it having the same limited
syntax as resolution and non-new
variables
most of those upper bonds are due to
sambus and neo-thapin who also showed
that lifting techniques cannot be used
for proving lower bounds against that
system
the lower bounds here are for different
mild generalizations of BC minus the
first was proved by Oliver Coleman and
the second by busanthapin
here's another reason why those systems
are interesting which will also serve as
a segue into our new results about them
in a really relaxed sense BC without new
variables simulates ER
let's parse this llama together it was
observed by Oliver Coleman back in the
paper where he defined block clauses
a form like gamma with an ER proof of
size n
then we can take this small cnfx
consisting of two Clauses that have some
new variables and attach X to gamma so
that the resulting formula has a proof
of size linear in them
this is not an actual simulation because
in BC minus we are actually proving a
different formula
it may seem like this result is not that
interesting because we are essentially
just incorporating new variables into
the formula
but a similar idea allows us to
construct some formulas to prove
separations across the different
generalizations of BC minus
and the nice thing is those curves are
completely modular that is we reuse the
same construction for multiple
separations and we are also able to use
previously in our upper and lower bounds
as complete Black boxes
we've finally come to talk about the
phrase that's in the title of our paper
I'll explain how to use what I call
guarded extension variables to prove
separations across different
generalizations of BC minus
we start with a formula with a short ER
proof keep in mind the result from the
previous slide where we incorporated
some new variables into the formula and
made it easy also for BC minus
to separate two systems p and Q that
generalize BC minus we will incorporate
extension variables in ways that are
useful to only one of the two systems
we will achieve this by guarding the
variables to make them hard to access
P will still be able to somehow use the
included variables to end up with a
short proof by simulating the ER proof
this is the upper bound
and Q will be completely unable to
achieve any speed up despite there being
some new variables present in the
formula and this is the lower bound part
in this way we will use a separation
between ER and Q to obtain a separation
between p and Q
this is made possible by the fact that
syntactic redundancy rules require some
conditions to hold for every single
clause in the formula
so we can guard the new variables by
some evil Clauses which can only be
overcome by some of the systems
here's a simple example of what I mean
using BC minus
with respect to this formula we know due
to the definition of a block Clause that
any Clause blocked for X has to include
both not Y and Y
which makes any such Clause useless for
shortening a proof
by scaling up versions of this idea we
can impose some restrictions upon the
set of redundant Clauses derivable in
each per system that we have
proving a separation then turns into a
balancing act where we try to limit the
abilities of one system while making
sure not to constrain the other one too
much
let's look at a summary of the results
we proved
here you see some generalizations of BC
minus
and those three
that are closest to it are its weakest
generalizations in qualitatively
different ways
the black arrows are relationships that
are already known the red ones are new
in this work
the way to read this diagram is as
follows
a solid Arrow from P to Q like this
means that P simulates Q
a dashed Arrow from P to Q with a circle
as the arrowhead like this
means that P is separated from Q and A
solid Arrow from P to Q with a gap in
between like this
means that P ball simulates and is
separated from Q hence is strictly
stronger
with variations on the recipe that I've
described in the previous slides we are
able to prove a whole bunch of new
separations
also in ongoing work we have the two
missing relationships here determined
conditionally and we are now working on
proving a lower bound against this SPC
minus system to make those relationships
unconditional and thus give a complete
picture of the relationships between the
systems on this triangle that are the
closest to BC minus
and by the way this SBC minus and spr
minus
are the systems which have those strong
upper bounds for the combinatorial
principles that I showed earlier
now in the rest of the talk I want to
explicitly show the proof of the
separations but I want to emphasize that
they're relatively simple at least
compared to improving separations
completely from scratch
and I will at least quickly show you
what the separating constructions look
like
in all of the constructions we are about
to see assume that gamma is some formula
with a short ER proof of size m
this Formula F of gamma that you see
here separates this spread minus system
from the elective
the asterisk means that the separation
is conditional
and the condition is that ER is
separated from the weaker system so we
read this statement as unless SBC minus
simulates ER it does not simulate rad
minus
now let's take a closer look at the
formula
first of all it contains gamma itself
it also contains M new variables x i
such that x i and not X I appear in
disjunctions with every Clause of gamma
it turns out that this formula is easy
for this rat minus system regardless of
whether gamma is
and the other two get no speedups
despite the presence of the new
variables here
this is another simpler one where we now
have two sets of new variables x i and y
i and those Clauses simply say x i if
and only if y i
this time red minus cannot make any use
of the new variables while the other two
can
and this is a more complicated one
because this SPC minus system is able to
do a lot of interesting things so it is
harder to work against but still this
construction gives a conditional
separation between those two systems SBC
minus and gu R minus
we are at the end thanks for making it
this far and let's conclude with some
take-home messages
so what we did is give a recipe for
improving separations between those
unusual proof systems in quite a modular
way
and by repeatedly using that recipe we
were able to give an almost complete
picture of the weakest generalizations
of this BC minus system
and if you're interested here are some
open questions that I'd like to see
answered
I think the most pressing one is to
prove some lower bonds against those two
strong generalizations of BC minus
like I said earlier I'm working on a
lower Bond against the first one here
SBC minus
and another issue is that we have all
those separations but they use
artificially constructed formulas
improved complexity people generally
seek to prove separations using
encodings of natural combinatorial
principles because those tend to give
you a more intuitive understanding of
the relative capabilities of the proof
systems so it would be nice to reprove
our results with more natural formulas
also as you might have already inferred
the study of those proof systems kind of
lives on its own Island right now
disconnected from the rest of proof
complexity some things are known for
instance we know that Bond adapt phrase
does not simulate BC minus due to an
existing lower bound
but I think the converse direction is
more interesting for instance is there
any subsystem of frege strictly about
resolution that even a very strong
variant of BC minus simulates
and finally we have a generic recipe in
this work
although it uses some properties quite
specific to the proof systems at hand
could it be maybe possible to somehow
adapt the high level idea for other uses
in proof complexity
and that's it thanks again for listening
also since I gave no explicit references
in the talk here's a list of papers to
look at if you're interested in previous
work